he was the man that paved the way for
China to become a superpower a man who
smoothed relations with the world and
did not shun its influence
Jung zimin was an unexpected choice for
leader he came to power in 1989 in the
wake of the Tiananmen Square protests
and Crackdown it was a time of great
division for the Chinese Communist Party
factions sympathetic to protesters
purged Jiang emerged as a Unity
candidate
[Applause]
he did much to repair China's damaged
reputation a rapport of sorts with world
leaders banter even that would be hard
to imagine now
he oversaw the peaceful handing back of
Hong Kong in 1997.
and achieved what previously might have
seemed impossible
successful bid to host the Olympics
his most lasting impact is likely in the
sphere of Economics he made his country
much richer he welcomed capitalists and
foreign investment and saw China join
the World Trade Organization
he was also more charismatic than some a
little eccentric even whether bursting
into songs
[Music]
whatever question he died here in the
city of Shanghai his home in his latter
years a place where he's remembered
fondly
he has given a lot of hope for us
Ordinary People and these hopes are
exactly what we want to see
modern China absolutely would not look
the way it does without Jung zamin he's
often credited as the leader that made
China rich but a lot of the instincts
that characterized his role in
particular and increased openness to
outside ideas have been reversed under
the current president Xi Jinping
and that may strike a nerve this week of
all weeks when China has seen the
largest demonstrations in decades a
chance perhaps for Flames to be found
there is a tradition that exists when a
big leader dies of people using that as
an opportunity to express their own
grievances so it happened when Joe and
Lai the Prime Minister under Chairman
Mao died back in 1976 it happened again
in 1989 ahead of Canada square but I
think we have to also Note One really
important difference from those earlier
times today China is much more heavily
surveilled
young-heeled vast influence here well
into his old age his economic reforms
were not matched by political
liberalization but his was a definitive
era Helena Smith Sky News in Shanghai